hello and welcome to Google cloud on-air
these are the live webinars from Google
cloud today we are hosting webinars
webinars every Tuesday my name is Elias
Pinto and I and with me I have I'm Sarah
Robinson we're based out of New York and
today we will be talking about Auto ml
vision to let you know week you can ask
questions anytime on the platform and we
have Googlers on standby to answer them
so let's get started so here is Sara
thanks Louis so today we're gonna talk
about Auto ml vision making custom image
analysis possible for every business
before we get into that let's talk about
what machine learning is so at a high
level machine learning involves teaching
computers to recognize patterns in the
same way that our brains do over time as
machine learning models are given more
examples and experience they're able to
improve and generalize on an input that
they haven't seen before so does anybody
remember how they learn their first
language her parents probably didn't
give you a dictionary and a bunch of
grammar books to memorize that'd be kind
of weird
instead you learned over time by being
exposed to many different examples so
let's say you were having pasta for
dinner you saw it on your plate you
heard your parents identify it
maybe you identified it incorrectly a
few times and were corrected over time
this repetition strengthens certain
pathways in your brain and this is
roughly how machine learning works - so
at a high level machine learning is
loosely based on how the human brain
learns instead of biological neurons we
have mathematical neurons that mimic
these neurons in our brain with machine
learning we can solve problems without
exactly knowing what the solution might
be
and finally machine learning enables
systems that improve over time as
they're given more and more data
so before I start solving a machine
learning problem and picking the tool
I'm going to use I like to think about
the type of ML problem that I'm solving
and on Google cloud platform we have a
spectrum of machine learning offerings
so on the left hand side we have
products that are targeted more towards
application developers if you're new to
machine learning and don't have any
machine learning experience we offer
five pre-trained API
these give you access to pre train
machine learning models all you need to
do to access them is make one REST API
request on the right side of the
spectrum we have products that are
targeted more towards data scientists
and those with a little bit more machine
learning experience and for this we have
tensorflow for building your own machine
learning models an ml engine adds our
managed platform for tensorflow so going
a little bit deeper into this if you've
got a common classification task that
someone else has solved before you don't
need to start from scratch you don't
need to build a model from scratch
trained only on your own data you can
utilize existing pre train models that
are out there but if you've got a
problem that's very specific to the type
of data that you're dealing with at your
company it's probably going to be a more
custom task that you'll need a more
customized solution for so let's take
image classification as an example let's
say you want to identify that there's a
cat in this image you've probably heard
this example before this has been done
many times before there's lots of models
that exist out there that have been
trained on hundreds of thousands of
images that can tell you if there's a
cat in an image or not so there's no
need to start from scratch although you
can if you'd like but fastest to utilize
a pre trained model that's already out
there to help you with this but let's
say for example that this is your cat
its name is Chloe and you want to
identify Chloe apart from other cats in
your image in your image data set so
this is a more custom task you're gonna
need to train a model on your own data
using label data so that it can identify
Chloe apart from other cats and animals
in your image library so let's start
with the machine learning api's we offer
five different api's that give you
access to a pre trained model to
accomplish common machine learning tasks
so you don't really need to know
anything about how these models work
under the hood to get started
you just pass it your image data for the
vision API for example you get back a
classification the video API does what
the vision API does for images but for
videos lets you analyze videos the
speech API lets you perform speech to
text transcription with the natural
language API we can further analyze that
text and with the translation API we can
translate text into over a hundred
different languages so these are our pre
trained api's targeted towards
application developers who want to
integrate machine learning in
their applications on the other side of
the spectrum we have tools to help you
build and train your models from scratch
so from the beginning the Google brain
team wanted everyone in the industry to
be able to benefit from all of the
machine learning product projects that
they were working on
so they made tensorflow an open-source
project on github and the uptake has
been phenomenal tensorflow is the most
popular machine learning project on
github last time I checked I think it
had over 90,000 github stars it also
just crossed over a million downloads
it's being used all over the world and
because tensorflow is open source you
can train and serve your tensorflow
models anywhere because we're focused on
Google cloud platform today I'm going to
talk about our managed platform for
tensorflow this is called cloud machine
learning engine and it lets you take
advantage of distributed training you
can distribute your training job across
machines using GPUs or TP use to
accelerate your machine learning
workloads once your model is trained you
can then choose to deploy it to machine
learning engine for serving so let's say
your ml model becomes a huge hit you're
getting thousands and thousands of
prediction requests every second you're
gonna need a scalable way to handle all
of those requests when you can use
machine learning engine to serve your
model a great thing about ml engine is
there's no lock-in
you can choose to train your model on ml
engine and then download it export it
and serve it somewhere else
optionally you can train the model
wherever you'd like and decide you want
to serve it on machine learning engine
another thing I like to think about when
I'm diving into a machine learning
problem is the resources that I'm gonna
need to solve that problem I've listed
just four here there's probably others
that I haven't thought of but let's go
over what these are
so first is training data how much
training data are you going to need to
get an accurate model that's going to
get an accurate prediction on your data
how much model code are you're going to
write how much training and serving
infrastructure are you gonna have to
provision and then finally overall how
much time is this whole process going to
take you so let's look at how this
applies to the products that I've talked
about so far so if we look at machine
learning as an API the great thing about
these API is is that you don't need any
training data to use them the model has
already been trained they're pre trained
models so if I wanted to I could
just generate a prediction on a single
image I passed that image to the API I
get a prediction back but it didn't
require any of my own training data I
also don't need to write any of the
model code again that's all handled for
you by the API and API is available on
Google cloud platform so I don't need to
worry about training or serving
infrastructure all it's gonna take is a
little bit of time to write my request
to the API and figure out how I want to
parse the response that I get back you
can get up and running with these api's
in probably less than a day let me talk
about two approaches to building a
custom model the first is transfer
learning which lets you take advantage
of a model that's already been trained
to do a similar task to what you'd like
to do so let's say you want to identify
where certain objects are in an image
there's lots of models that have been
trained to do this so you can utilize
the weights of these trained models and
then just modify the last couple layers
based on your own training data so with
this you will need some of your own
training data because the output is
going to be the predictions are going to
be specific to your data set you will
need to write some of the model code and
you may need to think about provisioning
training or serving infrastructure or
you may choose to use a managed service
for this and this will obviously take a
little bit more time than the pre
trained api's and then finally if you've
got a model built entirely from scratch
trained only on your data you're gonna
need a lot of training data for this to
work successfully you're also going to
need to write a lot of the model code
yourself think about where you're gonna
run your training and how you're going
to serve your model in production and
obviously this one will take even more
time than with transfer learning so
focusing specifically on image analysis
let's take a look at the existing tools
for image analysis on Google cloud
platform for that we have the cloud
vision API which lets you perform image
analysis with a single REST API request
these are all the features that the
vision API version API provides so at
its core the vision API offers label
detection which will tell you what is
this a picture of so for this image of
my return elephant animal etc then we
have web detection which goes a step
further and it will look across the
internet for similar images and then
based on the content
those pages it will provide additional
details on what's your in your image
then we have OCR or optical character
recognition OCR is able to extract text
from images so if any of you have ever
used the Google Translate app before and
taking a picture of a sign and then
seeing the translation in real time you
can use the vision API OCR method to
implement similar functionality into
your own applications logo detection
will identify common logos in an image
landmark detection will find landmarks
in an image crop hints can help you crop
your photo to focus on specific subjects
in the image and then finally we have
explicit content detection this is
pretty self-explanatory it will tell you
it's your image appropriate or not
this one is pretty useful across the
board for any any site or app that has
user-generated content instead of having
someone manually review all those images
that come in you can send it to the
vision API and then maybe you only need
to review a subset of those images as I
mentioned the vision API is a REST API
so you can call it in any language you'd
like the example code I have here is in
node J s and on Google cloud platform we
have a number of client libraries in
your favorite language that make it easy
to call all these api's so i'm using the
google cloud node module for the vision
API here I tell it the types of
detection I want to run I call detect on
that vision object passing it
I can either pass at a local image URL
or I can pass it the URL of a file
stored in Google Cloud storage I can
also just pass it the raw image content
basics before encoded so I pass it that
image the types of detection I want to
run and then I get a response back with
the detection x' and i can analyze that
response however I'd like to use that
data in my application so I don't like
to get too far into a presentation
without showing a live demo so I'm gonna
bring Elias on here to show us a demo of
vision API Thank You Sara so here we
have a chance to actually see how
powerful the the cloud vision API really
is and and to build on what Sara just
said it's really gives the ability to
understand what's in an image it's and
Google is very uniquely positioned to be
to provide you with powerful machine
learning models and let me show you how
easy it is this is a publicly available
demo that you can do and we're gonna go
and actually pull up some images here so
Sarah was kind enough to share some of
her recent holiday pictures and we
pulled up a picture she took in Poland
and right away what you see is that the
image the the machine learning model
immediately recognized that this was
taken in Krakow or a few polish as I
think you pronounce a crack off and and
it not only recognizes that landmark but
it's able to find out that it's also the
main market square and because of Google
Maps were able to pull exactly the
lat/long of where that picture was taken
let's look a little bit more into the
other labels that we have the other
entities that we recognize so we've
recognized the face see here we see the
human faces is picked out but also
please note the exact location of things
like eyes nose and mouth is correctly
identified we're able to also determine
a sentiment analysis so Sarah here looks
very joyful and even surprised at that
picture and as you can see they're very
likely those are the emotions she is
displaying on that picture must have
been a fun holiday so we can quickly see
there is a very long list of of labels
that we automatically assign to that
picture and we're able to see that it
under the the web entities we're able to
use the knowledge of the web about that
picture and actually pull it and does an
image search and compares that with the
information available on the web
I'll briefly mention here that we also
have safe search we can very quickly
identify that yes this is just the plain
holiday picture and it's safe to show at
any age last thing I want to show is the
JSON output it's a very long output out
but I'll just highlight some of the
types and positions of the different
labels so you see the left eye the right
eye and
so on and so forth for each one of the
labels that it identified it pulls it
gives you exactly where it is located on
the image let's pull up another image
and this one is a little busier Sara
again was very lucky to have gone to
Hamilton the show very recently so she
shared a picture as you can see this is
a much busier picture there's a lot more
going on a lot more different labels and
and and and and and other other elements
in this picture under faces right away
we picked her face here again with a
sentiment analysis we want to show now
here's the interesting bit we can show
things like on the web it recognized
correctly this was the Richard Richard
Rogers theatre and under texts I don't
know if you notice but the word playbill
is actually in the bottom there this
highlights the intelligence around OCR
that we have even if there's multiple
words in the picture we're able to
extract that to you if it's a piece of
text under the document we say it's a
menu or a form or a resume we're able to
pick different blocks of text and
display them on their pages and blocks
so this these are some of the things
that we wanted to highlight the good
thing is that this is publicly available
under cloud Google com slash vision and
you may test this on your own today a
quick reminder if I may if you want to
ask questions we ask you that you put
those questions throughout our
presentation so we're able to bubble
them up towards the end of our session
back to Sarah Thank You great demo so
back to the slides I want to revisit the
ml spectrum that I covered in the
beginning so remember that on the left
hand side we have products targeted
towards app developers machine learning
api's these are pre-trained api's you
can't customize them at all but they're
very easy to get up and running with on
the other side of the spectrum we have
products targeted towards data
scientists and machine learning
practitioners and these allow you a lot
more flexibility in building a custom
model train on your own data set so this
is what the spectrum looked like until
just a couple of months ago I'm super
excited about this new product that we
announced in January called Auto ml the
first product under auto ml is Auto ml
vision it's currently in alpha so you
need to be whitelisted to use it but
what auto ml does is you can see it
clearly fills a gap in this spectrum
what it does is Auto ml vision lets you
customize the vision API to your own
data set so let's say the vision API
works pretty well for you
but you've got some very specific images
that you wouldn't expect it to recognize
what they are but you want to generate
labels based on your company's very
specific data set now you can do that
with auto ml so this is what auto ml
vision provides it's essentially a UI
that helps you with every step of
building your model from importing the
data labeling it training a model
evaluating how well it performed and
then finally making predictions on that
model using data that it hasn't seen
before so the best way to show you auto
ml vision is to jump right into a demo
so for this demo let's say that I am a
meteorologist
maybe I work at a weather company and I
want to predict weather trends and
flight plans from images of clouds so
this begs the question can we use the
cloud to analyze clouds the answer as
you probably guess is yes so as I was
preparing this demo I didn't know much
about actual clouds before so I learned
a lot and I learned that there are many
different types of clouds as you can see
here and they all indicate different
kinds of weather patterns so my first
thought was to try this out with the
vision API I took a bunch of these
different cloud images and send them to
the vision API to see what I got back
now for us it's easy to see as humans
that these are completely different
types of clouds but the vision API was
trained on a huge variety of labels to
recognize high-level things so it knows
that there are clouds in these images
but even though these images are very
different types of clouds we get similar
labels back from the vision API
so this is where Auto ml vision comes to
the rescue so let's see a demo of auto
ml vision go back to the demo and what
we have here
is the UI for auto ml vision so as you
can see it takes us through each step of
building our model from importing data
label train evaluate and predict so the
first step here is to import our data
and there's a couple ways to do this we
can put all of our images in Google
Cloud storage and then we need to create
a CSV where the first column will be the
URL of that image the second column will
be the label associated with that image
now we can also build models that have
multiple labels for images for one image
then you just add extra columns to the
CSV for that particular image so in this
case I've already uploaded all of my
data and train the model so let's see
what happens here in the labeling step
so here is where I can review my image
labels so I can see what I've assigned
each image this data set I've already
labeled so this for example is a cumulus
cloud we've got a cirrus cloud here
let's say I label this one incorrectly I
can click on it and switch out the label
here but let's say for example that I do
not have time to label my dataset or I
had a giant data set and there was no
way I'd be able to label at all Auto ml
vision provides an in-house human
labeling service so the way this works
is you provide a set of instructions and
some exemple are images for each label -
these human labelers and in just a
couple of days
you'll get back a labeled image data set
for this case I already had a label data
set and just to look at a breakdown of
how many images of each type of cloud I
have here I'm looking at five different
types of clouds and we can see how many
how many images I have for each label
you only need ten images per label to
start training a model but Auto ml
recommends at least a hundred for high
quality predictions and you'll obviously
need more depending on what you're
trying to predict so the next step is
training your model and the great thing
about Auto ml is that you don't need to
write any of the model code that's
handled by Auto ml for you automatically
all we need to do is literally just
press this train button and we can
choose whether we want to train a base
model or a more complex advanced model
I'll get into that a bit later on
so once I've trained my model I'll get
an email when it completes
and my next step is to go in here and
see how my model performed there's a
bunch of different machine learning
metrics here what I want to focus on is
what's called a confusion matrix if it
looks confusing it's called a confusion
matrix but it's actually not that
confusing let's take a look
so in ideal confusion matrix we want to
see a strong diagonal down the top left
which is what we get here what this is
telling us is when we uploaded our
images to Otto amel it took a portion of
them to train the model but then it set
aside a small percentage of those images
to see how the model did on data that it
didn't see during training so this is
how the model performed on that smaller
test set of images so what this is
telling us is that for all of my images
that were actually altocumulus clouds my
model predicted 76% of those correctly
and we can see the percentages we get
all down here now for this model I
actually trained both the base and the
advanced version and auto ml has a great
way to compare different versions of
your model so let's say even if you just
train a bunch of versions of the base
model let's say you train it once with
500 images then you add 500 more images
and retrain your model and you want to
see how it performs so I can compare
them here and now I can see how it did
on the base compared to the advanced
model and this looks pretty good it
looks like this all of these went up
significantly when I went from the base
to the advanced model but hey wait this
one actually went down 12% and wouldn't
you expect the advanced model to perform
better across the board
well what this actually points out is
that there may be some problems with my
training data so if we look at where it
got confused it looks like it was
labeling a lot of my altostratus images
as cumulus clouds and I can actually
click on this and I can see the images
that my model was confused on so it
turns out that these images actually are
a little confusing and they may have
been labeled incorrectly and the
advanced model was able to identify
these shortcomings in my training data
for me so now I can go in next time I
update my model I can make sure to add
better images of altocumulus clouds
so the next step and the most fun in my
opinion is generating predictions on our
train model and there's a couple of
different ways to do this one is I can
use the web UI so that's what I'm going
to do right now I can upload an image
here and I can see what Auto ml vision
is going to predict so this was indeed a
picture of a cirrus cloud and this is
pretty awesome Auto ml is our model is
99% confident that this is a cirrus
cloud so we can use the UI to generate
predictions this is a good just quick
and easy way to check your model see how
it's performing right after it's been
trained but chances are you actually
want to build an application that's
going to query your train model and
there's a couple different ways to do
this I want to highlight one in
particular which is the vision API so
you saw briefly in the past slides what
a request to the vision API looked like
and what I want you to focus on here is
that the request really doesn't look
that much different with Auto ml so the
only things we need to add to our
request is this custom label detection
parameter and then once we train our
model we get access to this ID for our
train model and so we need to add that
to our request only I have access to
this model version or whoever else I
share this project with so let's say
that I'm using the vision API let's say
I had some weather app and first I
wanted my app only to detect is there a
cloud in this image I was using the
vision API but then I decided you know
what that wasn't actually good enough I
need to detect the types of clouds that
I'm seeing in these images I don't
really need to change much about how my
app is architected in order for that to
work I just need to switch out or add
this custom label detection parameter
along with the model that I've just
trained so that's how we generate
predictions on our model and to show you
how easy it is to build an app that uses
our train model I've built a super
simple web app here where I can upload a
photo of a cloud and we'll use this one
and it's gonna call my model I'm just
gonna tell me a little bit more about
that cloud so this is a cumulonimbus
cloud and if you see this type of cloud
while you're on a plane probably not the
best sign might be some turbulence so
this this is just a simple web app that
queries that model using the vision aid
which I just showed you and it gives us
a little bit more data on what these
types of clouds actually mean
so that is Auto ml vision gonna go back
to the slides and I wanted to highlight
some companies that are using auto ml
vision in production the first is Disney
Disney built a model train to identify
specific Disney characters products
categories and dominant colors that were
specific to the images that they have in
their data set and they've integrated
this model into Disney search engine and
it's helping their users get more
relevant results and find their products
faster Urban Outfitters is a clothing
company and they have a similar use case
to Disney they train a model to
recognize specific types of clothing
patterns and neckline styles and they're
using that to build a comprehensive set
of product attributes so through this
they're able to improve product
recommendations search results and
product filters the last example is the
Zoological Society of London Zoological
Society of London has cameras deployed
all over in the wild to identify
different types of wildlife in their
images and rather than having someone
manually review all the footage that
they're seeing they built an auto ml
model to identify all the different
types of wildlife that they're seeing in
those images so I definitely encourage
you to go learn more about Auto ml
vision you can go to cloud.google.com
slash Auto ml and there you can fill out
a form to sign up for the alpha we're
really interested to hear what types of
use cases you have for auto ml there's
more details in the blog post where we
announce Auto ml there's also an intro
video a podcast that goes into a little
bit more detail about how this works
under the hood and then if you want to
try out the vision API if you want to
use the demo that elias showed earlier
you can head over to cloud.google.com
slash vision to try that out with your
own images I definitely recommend doing
that let's say you want to see if the
vision API is right for your app but you
don't want to write any code yet so you
can just upload your images there see
the JSON response you'll get back and
see if the vision API is going to be a
fit for your application so thank you
and I'm gonna bring a line us back up
here so we're gonna be going into Q&A
here in just a moment so we were back in
a minute thank you
you
welcome back everybody hopefully you've
been busy putting some questions there
and we've bubbled up a couple of the
questions here to get us started so do
you want to take the first one here I'll
read it first so how do I sign up for
Ottawa now that is a great question to
sign up for auto ml go to cloud
google.com slash Auto ml and there
you'll see a link to fill out a form and
this is where we're collecting details
about the use case that you want to use
Auto ml for so we'll review that and
then you should hear back within a
couple of weeks or so let's see the next
question so you want to take this one
sure what industries do you see using
Auto ml the cool thing is that we are
democratizing the technology so really
any business that has that deals with
image data and which arguably is the
vast majority whether it is actual image
data that has and specifically I'm
talking about Auto ml vision here if you
have to as part of your business
identify things if you want to and we
talked about Disney about identifying
their their characters in that
intellectual property across a very
large data set we're able to really
apply the mature machine learning models
here to a lot of verticals like
manufacturing retail any sort of
customer-facing applications they're
they're way too many industries here to
to I don't want to limit ourselves
because even if you're just processing
resumes or or credit card
I'm not credit cards or business cards
we can do a lot to expedite what your
business does lower the costs of entry
because again it's a it's an API you
don't have to build another Google Data
Center we've done it and so you're able
to just leverage that and and just pay
for what you use okay I'll take the out
let me read the next one so how how do I
know whether I should use auto ml or
build an image classification map model
from scratch what is that one yeah
that's a good question so what Otto amel
excels at is image classification so you
give it a lot of image labelled images
it's able to output a label or tag for
that image but let's say you want to do
something a little bit more complex like
you want to identify bounding boxes in
your image so you want to say this is a
specific product that our company builds
and we won't identify where we where
we're seeing it an image with the
bounding box you would need to build a
custom image classification model with
tensorflow or cloud machine learning
engine to do that or let's say you
wanted to identify regions in an image
that's called masking so identify
labeling specific regions and whatever
types of images you're labeling that's
another use case for a custom image
classification model but if you if you
would like to do image tagging so output
some labels based on an image auto ml is
great across the board and the really
cool thing is it doesn't require you to
have to write any of that model code
yourself awesome let me read you the
last one the next one here
how long does trainee a model really
take and are there any best practices to
consider in order to speed up this
process or improve accuracy sounds like
somebody's really really wants to train
their model yeah that's a good question
I can take that one not so how long does
training model take for the base model
I found it takes about an hour maybe a
little bit less the advanced model for
my cloud data set which had about 1,500
images took just about 2 to 2 to 3 hours
to train although as you saw in the UI
the advanced model depending on how many
images you have can take up to four
hours to Train because it's a much more
complex type of model so it really
depends on how many images are in your
data set and a complexity of the variety
of those images some tips to improve
accuracy as I showed briefly looking at
the evaluate tab in the auto ml UI is
super useful I showed the confusion
matrix there are a couple other metrics
there but what I love about that
confusion matrix in the UI is that you
can actually click and see
what's being labeled correctly what's
being labeled incorrectly so I think
that's the best way to improve accuracy
on your model because you want to
remember that your model is only going
to be as good as a quality of training
data that you give it so that that
evaluate tab can help you identify
problems with your training data so then
you can go back look at the matrix and
see okay maybe a lot of my data was
mislabeled or maybe there just wasn't
enough of this particular label category
in my data set and you can go back and
improve it so once here you read the
next yeah let's go to the next one once
a model is built say for identifying a
particular brand of toy who owns that
model Google or the customer who built
it this is a really important question
to get answered
you own your data that's an important
point I'll say it again
you own your data Google does not own
the model we don't very important to
mention that we don't use we do not use
your data to retrain our models for
example Sarah showed the the cloud
classification that cloud training and
the data and in the pictures themselves
remain under Sarah's ownership and we
there there's a very hard break here
that we don't use that data or
information to Train anything outside of
it so folks that aren't worried about
intellectual property or should I be you
know how should i train my model should
I use my my my special sauce with with
my special pictures you feel that there
is no danger of that getting out and we
don't use that data to retrain anything
else outside of your own models okay
I'll read the next one we're on the last
one on this slide so so I want to
classify on a type of image or a brand
which isn't covered by the vision API
what can I use to extend a
classification that is already available
through auto ml / vision API I think you
touched on that a little bit yeah
earlier but I'll go back into it so I
mentioned with the cloud example so
let's say that I just want to know is
there a cloud in my image vision API is
great for that
then I wanted to go one step further and
say okay what types of clouds are these
maybe I'm using it to build a weather
analysis application then I can train a
custom model using auto ml another
example is let's say you've got a
product that's that's a new product part
of your that your companies just
launched and you want to identify all
the images that contain a picture of
that product since its new the vision
API will not be will not know what that
specific product is since that's
specific to your company so then you can
build an auto ml model to train it to
recognize all the images that contain
that you could do the same with a brand
or logo of a new product that you're
launching you can build a custom model
that's able to identify all of the
images that contain that brand in it
awesome I think we these are all the
questions that we have bubbled up here
so I think we're gonna move towards our
closing then if we may so where we have
more content coming down that following
this session so we invite you to stay
tuned the next session is around GG
sweeeeet security and they're gonna be
looking at the enterprise mobility
management the and also the enterprise
security protection and much more so
thank you again for spending last couple
minutes here with us we encourage you to
go to cloud Google comm to go deep and
wide on some of the subjects that we
covered to you today and thanks for
spending some time with us take care
thank you
you